the way we're going to get into this is
by as we so often do remembering where
we've been before okay now I know it's
warm and your brains are starting to I'm
overheating a little bit but I think you
can help me remember what the derivative
of log X is it's a really simple
function does any remember whatever X
very good quick note do you remember
even though it's not that big a deal but
it's still true it's actually a domain
restriction on this one over X do you
remember what it is it it's got to be X
is greater than zero now the reason why
it's this is because the function you
came from this log X function you
remember what it looks like looks like
this there you go there's your regular
old log X it only exists for X is
greater than zero if that's got a domain
restriction then it's derivative also
has a domain restriction does that make
sense yep very good now we then apply
chain rule to this so if you're doing
log of not X but a function of X do you
remember it's a it's a fraction just
like this but ever so slightly different
very good just rolls off the tongue
right F dash on F and in the same way
this f of X whatever it happens to be
has to be greater than zero right same
reason there's a domain restriction on
this thing right so I'm just going to
chuck that in here
that was a bad curly brace let's see if
we can make the second better that's
nice okay so derivative derivative are
you getting sick of me saying yet every
time you learn something that
differentiation you learn something
about integration right so I'm gonna
take each of these and I'm gonna turn
them into an integration statement okay
so do it one at a time let's do the top
one the integral of 1 over X DX equals
well where did we come from
log X yeah but as we can see this is
indefinite so there should be on the end
plus C very good okay so we're starting
to get the hang of this okay so that
looks fine I can have a look at this and
I can say something similar namely the
integral of F dash on F this read
rational thing with respect to X sorry
should be well where did I come from
what was the primitive here it is log of
the f of X plus obligatory constant
you're happy with that so there's
something interesting that happens this
is like 95% of everything you need to
know under this heading for now can you
please grab out your reference sheets
pull them out and I want you to find
where you can see one of these results
can you grab it for me
now once you search I'm looking to even
tell you what to look for but it's
something on the board there's only one
of them there are four things on the
board and one of them is on the
reference sheet have you found it which
one of the things I've written on the
board is on the reference sheet it looks
like it's this one doesn't it it looks
ever so suspiciously like it's this one
except it's not what's different
underneath this would you please write
for me the integral this is what's on
the reference sheet the integral of F
dash on F is in fact equal to the log of
the absolute value of this okay now this
leads to a question what's going on here
okay we saw what was happening here we
made some sort of reverse statements
some integration statements off the back
of these differentiation statements
everything looks fine where is this
coming from I want you to have a look at
the border just take a guess there's
enough information on the board that you
could sort of at least have a go at it
what do you see Erica have a look over
here we have domain restrictions on
these first two statements as Erica is
pointed out right domain restriction
domain restriction but there are no such
domain restrictions here so I haven't
accounted for the fact that these things
must be true okay now what does that
mean down here there are a few different
ways you can resolve this okay first let
me tell you a bad way to resolve this
okay you could say X is supposed to be
positive it's supposed to be I know how
to make numbers positive if they aren't
positive I will put absolute value signs
around them that would turn for example
negative five it would turn that into
five right now that's sort of true but
it does become positive but that's quite
it's pretty flimsy reasoning when you
think about it right because it's sort
of what because
you want it to be positive if you just
make it positive we've talked about this
before right if I gave you the integral
of something like X square root 1 minus
x squared ok
you'd have to do some kind of
substitution for this guy right
so you'd say I'll choose that as my
substitution like so in order to
complete the substitution you
differentiate this wouldn't you right so
you might do something like this now you
guys are at the point where you
recognize oh I have a minus 2x here I do
not have a minus 2x up here so I can fix
that I can make this a minus 2 provided
I compensate on the outside right you
see that that would actually be okay but
you can't just say I wanted to be minus
2 so I've just could have make it minus
2 anymore then you can say I want it to
be positive so I'll just make it
positive there's a more fundamental
reason a better explanation as to why
there are two good ones I'm gonna give
you the first one it's enough for you
guys to get working and I'll give you
the second one maybe later depending on
how much your brains over here maybe a
different day ok let's look at what this
would be like without all the chain rule
later
ok it would be this one but with some
obviously those so underneath here if
you've got the space the integral of 1
over X DX equals and instead of log of
the function of X our function of X in
this case is just X and as the reference
sheet tells us I slap my absolute value
signs faithfully on now I think this one
here put a box around it this one here
gives us a good reason to think about
why there should be absolute value signs
beside this over here if you've got some
space can you draw for me a set of axes
draw all four quadrants we're going to
need them
[Applause]
and onto this graph what I would like
you to do is put the 1 over X curve onto
your set of axes y equals 1 over X ok
now this thing here we've been we've
gotten far enough into calculus that we
can sort of look at all of this stuff
and more of it most of it more or less
makes sense right we're all just
shuffling symbols around and everything
is very symbolic I want you to go all
the way back to the start of this
integration topic what problem is
integration designed to solve it's an
area problem right now we know how to
find areas on here for instance here's
an area soup there's an area underneath
there right so I could find what that
area was if that was saying 1 to 2 I
could find out what that area was by
putting in the correct values right I
would form a definite integral using
this but what this tells you is like see
the 1 over X function it exists over
here do you see that it exists over here
quite happily whereas the log function
does not okay but there are areas over
here I should be able to find what they
are right so see how we said I have to
put a domain restriction because this
guy doesn't exist everywhere this one
does so you restrict right down here
this guy exists in some places like over
here where the integral the primitive I
should say doesn't right but we want it
to exist over there we want to be able
to get sensible values out of negative
values of X so therefore I need to put
absolute value signs because look
negative values of X totally exist for 1
over X so I'd better be able to put
suitable values into it okay that's not
the best reason I have a better reason
but it takes a bit more work and frankly
you don't really need it to actually be
able to do all of this so I'm gonna hit
pause on that and I'm going to let you
have a bit of practice just using this
and then we'll see if we have the time
and brain capacity to have a look at it
okay